okay hi everyone and I'm Eleanor I'm a
software developer at Salesforce and
today I want to talk to you about how we
develop an AI applications for
businesses at massive scale so we don't
just develop any AI application we
develop turnkey AI applications
what is turnkey AI so what it basically
means is that the customer doesn't have
to do anything for the AI to work at the
press of a button the AI starts
executing and start generating different
insights and predictions for the
customer so for the customer these are
good news because it's easy to deploy
and the customer doesn't have to hire a
team of data scientists to develop a
solution for him he just enables the
flow and the AI starts to work out of
the box but for the providers for us
it's a pretty challenging task we have
to provide an accurate solution for all
our customers and we're not just
providing any turnkey AI application we
need to provide an AI application that
works on customer data so we don't own
the data we have no control over the
data and the application has to work for
all our customers regardless their data
and we also obviously need to scale we
need to handle large volumes of data so
that's a pretty challenging task and
before I start describing the different
challenges and how we tackle them I want
to give an example of a turnkey AI in
Salesforce Einstein lead scoring so
you're probably all registered at some
point in a site like Amazon or Alibaba
or some other site not all of us are
aware of that but when we register in
these sites we actually become leads we
are registered as leads in Amazon and
Alibaba and other sites and that way
Amazon for example knows they can target
us we become a target so we are all
leads in different list of leads
somewhere and we're not even aware of
that so there are actually sales teams
working with lists large lists of leads
hundreds thousands of beads and their
goal is to actually convert these leads
into deals deals that they can close
when they actually sell the product so
how does a sales rep working with these
long lists how does he know where to
start which lead to contact first so
Einstein lead scoring actually gives a
score to each lead and not only it gives
a score it also explains the logic
behind the score the reasons why this
score was given to this particular lead
the score is given according to the
likelihood of this lead to convert to a
deal so now the sales are all he needs
to do is basically sort the list start
with relatively high scores leads that
have potential to convert to deals so
this is an example of a turnkey AI in
Salesforce the customer enables the the
lead scoring flow it doesn't have to do
anything doesn't have to configure
anything and it just works out of the
box so what kind of challenges are we
dealing with in scaling turnkey AI
applications there are many challenges
only mention a few so first of all we
have many different customers small
medium large enterprise customers and
this introduces different challenges
small customers from an engineering
perspective it might be easier to start
with small customers because they don't
have much data so the data fits in into
memory there aren't many performance or
memory usage concerns but from an AI
perspective they might not have enough
data to train good models for large
customers the the it's it's completely
different because
the data is more complex
they usually have different business
units different teams and we also need
to handle that for example they can have
a team selling laptops and a different
team selling storage units these two
teams work completely different they
have different leads data and we need to
think about it when we provide an AI
solution for them and we'll see how we
tackle this challenge later on another
challenge that we have is computing and
competing with in-house solutions so
some customers have their own in-house
solutions they obviously have the home
advantage right because they know their
database best they can have a
tailor-made solution that is tailor
tailored to their needs and to their
data and they also get constant feedback
from their sales reps we can't do that
we can't tailor the solution to a
specific customer remember we're
actually developing turnkey AI solutions
they should work on all our for all our
customers regardless their data so we
can't tailor the solution and that's
pretty challenging we have to make it
work for everyone and we've actually
seen examples many example examples
where the turnkey solution was worked
better than the in-house solution
another challenge that we have is the
trade-off between accuracy and
performance so we could train thousands
of models in production and use
thousands of different features and
increase our sample size and by doing
that we increase the accuracy of our
model right
but our application won't scale it won't
work it will be extremely slow our
memory consumption will be extremely
high and we can't we can't really do
that we have to find a good balance
between the two between accuracy and
performance so we've mentioned
you challenges how we how do we tackle
these challenges step-by-step so first
we have to cover the basics in any
application not just AI applications
when you want to scale your application
you need to think of a large-scale
architecture a caching mechanism
parallelism code optimizations whether
you're working with Python or any other
language for that matter database
optimizations network optimizations and
the list goes on but maybe the most
important thing in the list is testing
and monitoring testing and monitoring is
crucial and we use tools like data dog
which you're probably familiar with
Splunk logs and other monitoring tools
obviously you also need performance
tests in place accuracy tests in place
and once you have the basics covered how
do you actually scale your AI
application from the AI perspective how
do you do that step by step from
collecting the data through training
through the prediction phase and finally
the evaluation phase so let's start with
a collect data when we get the data when
we first collect the data we only get
the deltas when we get leads we only get
new and updated leads we don't need to
refresh the data all over again so
that's one very simple optimization we
also fetch the data in batches and think
about it you have we can have millions
of beads we don't need to use all these
leads and we can't really use all these
leads in training so we sample the data
and finally we also clean the data we
allowed the user we allow the customer
some level of control and the customer
can actually exclude certain fields or
filter certain leads that he doesn't
want to get scores and this is called
field exclusion and row level filtering
moving on to the Train model phase
you have to decide on the retrain times
when do you really need to retrain your
models how frequently do you need to do
that and if it's not as frequent as
providing the predictions a good idea
would be to separate between the two
between the training and the prediction
and we do that we have different floats
for that how do you select a model for
all your customers do you use the same
model for all customers so we will see
how we tackle that later on
what about feature generation and
selections so you can actually use rare
values and top values and reduce the
number of features and that way you use
only meaningful and interesting features
that can really help your model and
improve your model results moving on to
the prediction phase when we score our
leads when we provide the prediction we
do that in parallel and again we upload
the results in batches and when you
upload massive amounts of data you have
to have a retry mechanism in place
because there will be failures it won't
work if you won't have a return
mechanism finally in the model
evaluation phase you need to think of
evaluation methods do you use the same
model and the same method for all your
models obviously each model may be can
has you have a different way of
evaluating it so you need to take that
into account you also need to have a
dashboard like a single view where you
can track your model see how your model
is doing how it's doing over time view
different trends aggregate results
across different customers and again
testing testing is important so you
should have accuracy regression tests in
place you can actually have a test that
checks if your model is not accurate due
to code changes maybe it can prevent
deployment or if your code is executing
longer than expected again you can
prevent deployment so let's see some
after we've seen like a high-level
description of how we can handle that
and how we can scale our code in each
step
let's see some concrete examples so the
first example is related to the collect
data phase so some some of our features
use emails data and analyze emails data
to create different insights the emails
are actually stored in Amazon s3 they
online object storage and the emails
that we've already fetched from Amazon
s3 are stored only their keys are stored
in a [ __ ] collection so the emails flow
goes as follows we first get the list of
emails stored in Amazon s3 just the keys
and then we match them with the emails
that we have in our [ __ ] collection and
we see which emails we need to fetch
which are which emails are new and we
don't have in our [ __ ] collection and
we need to fetch them from Amazon s3 so
we've noticed in our data dog dashboard
that this flow took us longer than we
would expect and investigating this
issue we found that the bottleneck was
actually the matching phase matching the
emails from Amazon s3 to our [ __ ]
collection and the matching was
processed in using Python threads and
the global interpreter lock in python
was actually the root cause for this
issue so the global interpreter lock the
jail prevents python threads from
executing python code at the same time
but when a thread is waiting for an i/o
operation for example then a different
thread can take over and continue its
execution the developer the chose Python
threads
in implementation here had an assumption
he assumed that most of the time would
be spent on IO operations but actually
that wasn't the case most of the time
was spent inside the jail matching
emails in memory between the [ __ ]
collection and s3 so the solution here
was to replace the thread implementation
with salary tasks and this actually
reduced our decreased our processing
time from over a hundred minutes to 20
minutes this was a major decrease in
processing time
so obviously the conclusion here is to
use fights on threads cautiously but
also to monitor your code so you will be
able to detect these bottlenecks and
later solve these issues when you
encounter them another example in the
collect data phase is the enrichers
example we actually have enrichers in
place that in reach the data when we get
the leads data we add more and new and
interesting features over the data for
example we have the phone validity
enricher that adds whether phone is
valid or not
and this enrichment work takes time the
execution takes time the problem was
that the enrichers were part of the
training so it increased the training
time significantly so what we did we
actually moved our enrichers logic
outside of the training so it's really
important to decide when you're going to
do which job if it takes longer if you
can separate between these jobs it's a
good idea you don't have to enrich the
data after training so if previously the
every time we retrained in reach was
triggered now in reach is triggered once
when we collect the data only for new
and updated leads that way the training
flow gets the leads already in reach
and that saves us a lot of time moving
on to the training model face so how do
we select a model do we use the same
model for all our customers so the
answer is no we can train multiple
models for each customer we evaluate
each of the models in production and we
choose the best model we choose the
winner for each customer so for example
in this example customer a had a
different winner
xzx G boost classifier customer B for
customer B the winner was random forest
so each customer gets the best model fur
for him
what about large customers so we've
talked about how large customers have
complex data and complex structure they
have different business units different
teams a team selling laptops a different
team selling data storage units and
these teams were completely different
they have different leads and we can't
really train the same model for all
these teams so data segmentation comes
to the rescue
the customer can actually configure the
data segmentation and divide the leads
into different segments different teams
and then we can train multiple models
for each segment for each team and
choose a winner again this time not for
a single customer but for each segment
we choose a winner what about small
customers so small customers as I said
earlier don't don't have enough data for
training good models so we're currently
thinking about using global models
combining data from multiple small
customers and training and global model
on the combined combined data can have
good results for all these customers if
we train the model separately it might
not result in good results for all of
them
another example I want to give related
to training a model is how we tuned our
parameters using grid search so we used
for lead scoring we used extra boost
classifier now eczemas classifier has
many different parameters how do you
choose the right combination
there are many parameters do you examine
all the parameters so a grid search is a
really complicated task think about it
we have n customers if we're examining
leads from different times say one month
ago two months ago three months ago etc
we have t different time frames we have
P parameters and for each parameter in a
vexed reboost there RV possible values
let's say so there are endless
possibilities here in a single run we
need to get leads for a particular
customer from a particular time frame
train the extra boost model using a
specific configuration evaluate the
model and finally store the results this
is just a single run but we need to do
that millions of times we need to
execute millions of runs even if we
choose what we perceive as small numbers
for in TP and V we get millions of runs
that we need to execute to examine all
these options so that's not feasible so
how do we approach such a complicated
task so first you have to know your
limits you have to know how many
machines you have to execute and how
many runs you can actually execute in
the time that you have you can't just
read search forever so you have time
limitations obviously you need to know
how many runs you can execute once you
know that you can start narrowing your
search so you choose subsets of
customers subsets of everything we
talked about the end the P
whatever we choose subsets of parameters
subsets of values and you can also use a
two-level search when it comes to the
parameter values because obviously each
parameter has many possibilities for the
values that we choose we can start with
widespread values and then tune as we go
and finally you can think of different
optimizations for example storing data
for reuse between runs so if we're only
changing the extra boost classifier
parameters and we're not changing the
the other pipeline steps like feature
generation feature selection that
happened before the extra boost
classifier we can store their outputs
and reuse them in the next runs you
should probably also think of a recovery
mechanism and you can also prune bad
configurations so if at some point you
identify a configuration as bad you
decide what the point of identification
is when you identify a bad configuration
but once you identified a bad
configuration you just no longer examine
it a recovery mechanism means that if
the execution suddenly fails so how do
you continue your execution from the
last point
okay so grid search is obviously very
complicated you have to think of many
things you have to consider many things
when you approach this desk one last
thing that I want to mention in the
Train model phase is that every change
that we do we have to do it carefully
whether it's adding a new feature or
removing an existing feature whatever
changes we're doing to our model can
improve for one customer and harm
another so we have to
everything and we have to research
everything before we just deploy it to
production and we do research it using
Jupiter obviously and we also use paper
mill for executing parameterised
notebooks and we do that in parallel by
running multiple processes after we
finish the research phase we have to
make that transition from research to
production you have to make your code
production ready obviously many
libraries work well in research but that
doesn't mean that I want to use them in
production because they're error-prone
because it doesn't cover the basics that
we've talked about earlier it doesn't
scale well for example pondus is more
error-prone so we we've decided not to
use it in production and once you've
made your code production ready again
you should have accuracy regression
tests in place to prevent deployment if
your model is suddenly inaccurate due to
the changes that you've made so if you
take aways here obviously dealing with
scale is is complicated for any
application but for turnkey AI
applications it's extremely complicated
and you have to think about not a single
customer you have to cover and think
about every customer all your customers
from small to large that have different
challenges and you also need to think
about the trade-off that we've talked
about trade-off between accuracy and
performance and you have to make your
code production ready and that's not
easy
and finally testing and monitoring is
crucial you should always have
performance tests in place accuracy
tests in place to cover the flow that's
a thank you thank you
have you considered using a scalable
language such as Scala instead of button
and a scalable framework such as apache
spark so we um we're currently we're
currently using Python and not Scala I
don't know if it's in our roadmap to use
Scala but Python is a is a good language
for a I code so we're relying on Python
right now when it's working well for us
I don't know if maybe there will be
plans in the future here something yeah
so the question was how do we decide
when to retrain our models of how do we
train our so we actually and retrain
there are there are multiple flows so
first of all if as I said before we
allow the customer to have a certain
level of control so if the customer
changes a certain configuration
obviously we retrain we trigger retrain
so that's one aspect and another aspect
is basically we've learned that in leads
pouring so each product is it's
completely different but in lead scoring
I think we train every 10 days or so so
we have different retrain times and
we've learned that's enough and that's
good enough for us yeah so we actually
it's really complicated but what you're
asking is if we need to make changes
after deployment how do we do that and
does it affect
all the releases or previous releases so
in Salesforce it's really complicated
because we actually in lead scoring for
example we can make changes to our model
and it will affect directly to the
customers we can make changes and we can
make changes relatively fast it will
reach the customers pretty soon but
again it depends it's a pretty
complicated question because it depends
which changes and ultimately what we
what we promise for the customers is the
most important thing so we won't break
that and it depends which change we're
talking about obviously but if it's
something if we identify something we
can improve in our model we can do that
usually fast change
[Music]
of course we every change we make we
have to test it we have to research it
so do we know if our cost how our
changes will affect the customer so we
can we can know we can know to some
extent we can know by doing this
research that I've talked about we do
that before deployment before the the
solution reaches our customers and then
we can detect many issues many problems
in the research phase and not harm the
customer in any way but we obviously
have a direct connection to the customer
we get customer feedback and we are able
to find to get feedback from our
customers as well it's a very good
question
how we measure performance and yeah so
any other questions okay so the question
is regarding salary tasks how do we
monitor it how do we prevent them from
getting stuck so as I said before we we
have many monitoring tools that we use
which are really effective like data dog
and spline clogs and we use all these
monitoring tools to detect issues if
there are any and then we can solve them
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you